your starting pitcher for the twins
today is griffin jacks making his eighth
start two strikes
and there's a breaking ball a swinging
strike three and then that's that slider
right there but even that pitch up in
the strike zone the break on that how
late it is it's a weapon for him
swinging in the miss and that wraps up a
good inning for griffin jacks
issuing a two out walk the runner left
aboard no score after a half and they'll
go up against aaron ashby pitching for
the first time since he was in relief on
sunday against washington one and two to
polanco
drill to the left field corner and that
one will stay fair
polanco rounds first digging for second
ball stays in the corner and he thinks
about third but he will hold up with a
double he just continues to hit it's
both sides of the plate
and this one off ashby's glove
right to wrong all worked out well for
the final out there in the first early
start no score they head to the second
inning
and a fastball with 94 gets a swing of
the miss
and he's got much better location with
his fastball than he does with the
breaking ball here's zaria spatting
and this one launched left field way
back
and gone right on cue
for urias home run number 18 on the
season
and the brewers are on the board and out
in front early against the twins second
deck
luisa
getting a slider right down the middle
of the plate griffin jacks has given up
now 15 home runs taking care of his guys
down there yep
this one hit a ton center field buxton
watches it go over his head off the top
of the wall
and jackie bradley jr with a two-out
double
fly ball center field couldn't be more
routine for buxton
a couple of extra base hits they only
run on a home run it's one nothing
milwaukee
and the 1-0 pitch ground ball right side
basin right field now sanel said last
night post game that he was working on
that in the batting cages underneath as
batting practice was rained out
yesterday and letting that ball travel a
bit more thinking about right field
right center the shift on cinahl saw
that space between first and second base
and smacked it to right for a lead off
hit hauser is pitching well all season
long
3-2 again and a big strikeout for ashby
another slider
a good time here today
and his swing and
he'll secure it at first base nice job
out there by narvaez
so a leadoff single
goes for nah as ashby takes care of
business
94 buzzed over the inside corner another
strikeout for jax is fourth in ten plate
appearances
3-2 to ellich lined into left field and
over the head
of rooker to the wall
that had some sizzle on it and kristen
yelled opposite field a bullet over the
head of rooker now an eight-game hitting
streak for christian yellets here's
teles batting for the second time
and this one crushed
all the way back
upper deck
a three run two-out home run for rowdy
toles
number 11 on the season
and it's four-nothing milwaukee that's
how you break out of it boy rowdy teles
i mean he can hit some monumental blasts
no doubt that's one of them 108 miles an
hour off the bat
454 feet away from one place emily
junior doubled his last time up
buxton
to the gap
leaping and making the cash
that ball was creamed and buxton was
able to get there for out number one the
athleticism
of byron buxton it just
it
he makes these catches look so easy
peterson at first one out here the
brewer half of inning number four
and this one into left field the base
hit for reyes
peterson on his way to third
and milwaukee's got something going
again here in the fourth inning gold
wong now top of the order he has struck
out twice in this one and this will line
down the right field line
and it's gonna play to run for milwaukee
two runs come home
not messing around a couple of
strikeouts for colton his first two
times up jumps on the first pitch and
here's miguel cino here's a deep blast
to left
wow
quickly into the second deck
gets the twins on the board with his
23rd home run of the year yeah that's a
good swing by cino we've talked so much
about his approach and in his first ep
hitting a change up the other way and
that's not something we've seen we've
seen him talk about his approach and
hitting baja in the middle and then
getting a hanging breaking ball and we
will welcome to the major league club
ian jebeau colton wong top of the order
and this one sliced the other way
and long on his way to second base
and he'll trot in
with a two out double for milwaukee here
in the sixth inning not messing around
back to back doubles for colton wong on
the first pitch
breaking ball away good inning for jabot
in his twins debut issues
or allows a two-hour walk no damage done
it's still 6-2 and hunter strickland
comes in now here in the sixth inning
josh donaldson is oh for two
and also
the one hopper passed a diving uranus
it's a two-out hit gives sono another
chance with a man aboard count even two
balls two strikes two down strickland
delivers
and he got him looking
strike three and he gets through the
inning
dump to right a base hit for ostadio his
first and it's another hit after the
second out one's got a two out single on
the six and now off the deal is aboard
for simmons luis arise pinch hitting
here in the seventh inning with two down
there's a runner at first
and this one to short
marias for the final out
so the brewers through seven
maintain a 6-2 lead over the twins
and bradley jr another base hit to right
about him i mean he talked about some
good contact for jackie bradley jr
right three of the four times up tonight
he's been hitting the baseball hard
ureas at third reyes at first and wong
who struck out his first two times up
sono back to the bag takes the throw
from polanco and chabot has given the
twins three shutout innings as the twins
come to bat against josh hayder
appearance number 48 on the season for
the brewer all-star closer
to left sharply hit
and donaldson on an o2 pitch drills a
single left
swing and a miss and there's your first
down or not
right at the top of the strike zone got
him on strikes
3-2 on the way and there's another
strikeout for josh hayder there's your
second out here in the ninth
one two on the way strike three game
over
and the brewers win it six to two and
have allowed two runs or fewer in 56
games now the best mark in major league
baseball
you